Chào các bạn, các bạn, các bạn ảnh trẻ qua tình trạng suốt luôn nhất chạm.
Thao các bạn, ín cứu vào đổi mới của giai Indonesia,
nhiều khu vực chục thành phố, chính từ mời đến bác mươi sinh tìm ấy mỗi năm,
giòn này rất tự nhiên và khai thác nước ngầm giao sài.
Tốt đồ này khiến chức tàn trở thành một trong nhiều lâu thiện suốt luôn nhàng nhất thế giới,
làm tăng quyết gần gặp lột trong một cạnh thủy chio gió mua và sống lớn ngày càng phức tạm.
Để uống phó, Indonesia chìn khai nhiều biển phát, nhiều năng từ chám biển,
sẽ chặt khoal y khai khai khách nước ngầm và phục hồi dừng gặp mạng.
chính phố cũng đúng đầy giữa ăn tương biển dài, bây chăm kêu lắm hết,
giọc bờ biển bác chá và bây chi phía tính tảm vi tìm đúng là Mỹ và ký vọc,
khuy đạo vôn quá tắc tổng tư.
Sống sống mới đau, kế hoạch chuyển, tủ đồ sang, nu sân tà ra, tư đúng đời chín khai,
dụt đến đồ xây dân kiện mới đặt khoảng nơi làm phần chăm,
và ngồn bộ tương nhận vẫn còn hạnh trẻ.
chính phố in lưu đi siê khẳng đệ,
quá chính vất chỉnh tủ đồ mới và nở dưới chi,
nhằm dạng tài cho chắc tà,
thành phố đang chữ sức f lớn tự sột lốn vàng bộ tương.